josh brolin is bringing a new iconic  villain to life  Thanos is a very complex character what  he's doing from his point of view is a  very positive time  he's basically an eco-terrorist and he  wants to eliminate 50% of the universe  to save the other 50%  [Music]  we wanted to tell a story about a  character with a really complex and  empathetic interior life  [Music]  there's not a lot of actors that can  give you both of those things Josh  Brolin brings a reality to the character  he is wearing that Moe Cup suit he's  wearing that motion capture cameras the  performance is coming through not only  in his gestures in his face but in his  eyes there's about 2,900 visual effects  shots in the movie we wanted to make it  as photographic as possible and I think  that that's the most important part  you